hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today I would like to talk
about a sheer force of terror who has
been conjured in the realm of hunter
hunter during the succession war Ark
being 4th Prince
sir I'd Nick qui Goro and I'd like to go
into this because I believe that he
really is an unparalleled existence in
hunter hunter they really aren't a lot
of antagonists like him who are able to
conjure the sense of genuine fear I mean
the greatest antagonist in the series
Hisoka illa mean crow la marihuana all
of them have features that end up
endearing them to the watchers and
readers of the series whether it be
aspects of comedy being able to portray
or emphasize for their perspective in
life well even in the case of Hisoka
just become a straight-up protagonist
sometimes sir I'd Nick does not exist
within this sort of realm there is a
very defiant line that separates him
from each of the aforementioned
villainous presences although right at
the outset I should say that the
succession war is obviously nowhere near
over and there is still time to play sir
I'd Nick into this basket if took a she
so desires but I highly doubt that's
happening simply from the way in which
he was set up to be one of if not the
most putrid and blatantly sinister
existences within Hunter hunter in fact
one character in the series has already
described Surat Nick as pure unbridled
evil words which I entirely believe but
first of all just some background as
mentioned before Surat Nick is the
fourth eldest legitimate prince of the
car cane Empire and so he has made it
comfortably into adulthood and granted
extensive resources of the Empire
surpassed only by his three older
siblings and of course the king himself
interestingly enough though despite
being the fourth Prince sir and Nick was
actually born of the first queen of the
Empire being unmasked we caught all who
initially looks just like a female
Prince Benjamin and that's for good
reason actually because the other child
she gave birth to was first Prince
Benjamin and this herbs is much more
than a mere fun fact because the customs
of the cocking Empire are not as simple
as I'm the first print so I have
priority over all lesser Prince's
because there is another layer in
addition to this in regards to how the
queens are ranked and suraíh Nick being
born of the first queen
actually puts him on something of an
equal standing to first Prince Benjamin
as well as second Prince Camilla and
third Prince angle a well add two to
being born before sir add Nick however
they were spawned from the second and
third Queens respectively which in a
weird political way kind of balances out
their standing I guess what I'm trying
to say is a be aware that coming into
this to write Nick has no real
disadvantage in terms of his ranking
amongst the princes making him a prime
candidate to win the succession war
before we even begin to the
aspect of it although the core of this
is what really separates Surat Nick from
his 13 other siblings which are two
primary factors being his vision for the
world as well as his natural talent for
acquiring the power to make that a
reality
and in terms of said vision this is
probably a great time State that's right
Nick is a self-confessed man of culture
and artiste if you will however his
interest seemed to extend to all facets
of culture such as sports and in fact
Surat Nick is also a football fan
specifically however innocent as all of
this may sound so rad Nick's artistic
pursuits are even more obscure and
disgusting than Hank Jackson Pollock
painting if you could believe that that
is but you probably can't essentially
sir at Nick's primary area of interest
is in the exploration of the idea of
youth put in an extreme situation a
synthesis of the arts as he refers to it
and one example of this pursuit we're
seeing during Surat Nick's introduction
into the series where he invited two
young girls to his lavishly decked out
hotel suite and proceeded to brutally
murder them both for the sake of art now
it's currently unclear as to what aspect
of this practice right Nick considers to
be art but if I had to guess I would say
that sad Nick is more the type of person
who creates art for the process rather
than the result in fact I'd say that the
result is all but irrelevant to him so
it's not like he'd be using their bodies
to create some sort of elaborate
sculpture or something no that's far too
pedestrian for this Renaissance man
which should only terrify you more
because at least if that were the case
what he would do is kill you quickly
and user remains for whatever purpose he
saw fit instead Sarat Nick's goals are
centred entirely around his victims or I
guess in his mind his subjects emotional
response to whatever horrors he chooses
to inflict on them another way of
putting it would be to call him an
extreme sadist but once again I highly
doubt that's a term that sir I think
would ever apply to himself because it's
just too general in fact sir I'd Nick
has very high standards of his victims
referring them to be widely studied and
to have the same level of appreciation
for high culture as he does if a person
holds anything less than two riding it
considers them to be subhuman and that
doesn't just apply for the general
public either surrounding even feels
this way about several of his own
siblings despite the fact that they were
raised in a royal environment to add to
the grotesque Adisa Suri Nick is not an
insular artist either meaning that he
does actively appreciate and become a
patron of the work of others which has
led him to becoming a prolific body part
collector and in fact prior to karapa
cos quest for revenge Sarah and Nick
held the world's largest private
collection of scholar dies
dude from the coat plant and in fact as
it is he still holds a staggering amount
of them given their market value and he
will also seem to possess an even rare a
whole head of a kurta clan member
alongside any number of other Horrors
such as his personal throne which
appears to be constructed from rare
remains now if you haven't quite gotten
that sick to your stomach feeling just
yet I just like to really hammer home
the point of how absurdly dangerous
impassioned artists can be they aren't
people who can be easily swayed by logic
in the same way that other classically
evil professions can be like for example
a corrupt businessman who understands
the constant factor of profit or a
dictator who takes every logical step in
order to attain and consolidate power an
artist is very different because they
are driven by their personal whims at
the time and they can take any form
that's why artists can be some of the
most inspirational people this world has
ever seen as well as the most terrifying
and in surratt next case it's well it's
certainly the latter because he is
driven by passion rather than logic and
passion we'll take you to a hell of a
lot more extremes than logic ever will
and all of this isn't to say that suraíh
dick is an individual disconnected from
emotion himself because if there's one
thing I can guarantee you that this man
actually feels it is anger sir and nick
has a particular distaste for women who
he believes to be quote lying [ __ ]
and as such being a woman and trying to
keep something from Surat Nick or even
worse trying to actively undermine him
is probably the worst possible position
one could ever put themselves in just
ask theta who we'll get to in a bit so
Surat Nick already has the mindset of
one of the most alarming individuals
this series has ever known the only
thing that could make that worse is if
he had the sheer power to enact his
twisted pursuits and unfortunately I'm
here to report to you that he most
certainly does so keep in mind
everything I've said about his position
within the royal family this man already
has access to resources and manpower
that very very few people will ever be
in the position to experience but even
that pales in comparison to the power
that has been awakened within him aboard
the black whale one during the
succession war after submitting to the
seeder in ceremony each of the princes
have been granted a guardian n beast
which the princess cannot see or even
control even if they noon in previously
sir I'd Nick was one of the majority who
despite his limitless resources and loss
for knowledge had never even heard of
the concept of Nan prior to the
succession war and in a different
reality men may have gone unnoticed by
him for the remainder of his days
however in this unfortunate reality Cora
pica just so happened to announce the
existence of Nan base over the emergency
and so sir addicts curiosity was sparked
I mean to be fair to crop oka he had no
idea that the princess was still in the
dark at this point but regardless he had
no idea what he was about to unleash
upon the world sir ad Nick Roth
predictably insisted on investing the
bulk of his time and resources to study
the art of net and he even found an
unwilling teacher amongst his own guards
a woman by the name of theta who we
mentioned before and possibly the only
individual aboard the park rail one who
currently realizes what an incredible
danger Serena could become with access
to even the basics of known however
under duress from Surratt Nixon and
Beast theta agreed to teach him planning
to find a moment to assassinate stride
Nick before his evil could be unleashed
upon the world and you know this might
actually be a good reason to mention
that Surratt Nick is exactly the reason
why nen is such a tightly guarded secret
in Hunter hunter civilization because it
does essentially respond to the will and
desires of those who wield it meaning
that it has the potential for great good
and great evil and so right Nick has
more potential than most as eventually
he got theta to perform the water
divination ceremony for him and it was
discovered that he was a specialist
making his potential in the art of nen
nigh on unlimited twine to this ride
Nick is simply a genius and his natural
talent for nen is second only to
marijuana in the history of the series
Saran dick managed to achieve insane
feats like mastering geo within a single
day as well as move on to the more
advanced applications of both 10 and Ren
within a mere few days
although by far his most impressive
achievement to date was at Surat Nick
somehow managed to unconsciously summon
an entire nen Beast meaning that he now
has to be set his disposal in the
succession war both of whom exert power
so extreme that they make the other
conjured beasts look cute in comparison
and not only that but Sir I'd Nick is
also well on the way to developing his
first fully fledged Tatsu and
essentially allows him to look briefly
into the future and it would be this
hard sue that would allow him to prevent
data from assassinating him at this
stage it would seem that every second
Surat Nick is allowed to live and
progress in nen
results in him becoming an increasingly
astronomical threat to everyone and
everything within this world and I know
it might not seem like that at the
moment but this voyage and therefore the
succession war has a maximum time limit
of two months and we've really only just
begun and yeah there are serious
defining figures aboard like Cora Parker
crowing Sokka
or even the entirety of the zodiacs who
if they got in early enough may be able
to stop Surat Nick but nobody is going
to truly understand how much of a threat
he is in time for
like that to have worked this man is
going to take the Blackwell one by storm
and is terrifying a thought as that is
it's also quite an exciting narrative
one because I have to praise the skill
of Takashi for managing to introduce a
late-stage villain that seems like
you'll actually be able to hold his own
if not completely eclipsed the current
establishment of characters whatever way
this turns out Sir Enoch is going to go
down in history as one of the most
brilliantly sinister characters not only
in hunter hunter but also the entire
medium of manga as we know it and that
pretty much does it for why this twisted
artist dude should terrify you all if
you enjoyed this video and the content
this channel produced in general then
please do consider donating to the New
World review patreon because the support
of all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan read takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on sir I'd Nick this has
been the new world review and I'll see
you next time
you